(alarm clock buzzing)
- [Ed] We usually get up about 7:00.
- [Marsha] Yeah, and I
usually get up a little later.
- [Ed] I make coffee for both of us.
- [Marsha] I like honey
and cream in my coffee.
- [Ed] And then, I almost
always drive to work.
Our morning routine is quite mundane.
- [Marsha] Oh, yeah.
One thing we're doing today
is the fire-breathing dragon,
finishing off that.
- [Ed] Yeah, and I've
got some stuff to blood,
and some skulls, and pumpkins.
- I'm Marsha, this is my
husband, Ed, and we run
Distortions Unlimited.
- We make monsters: zombies,
aliens, dragons, and beasts
of all kinds.
- Oh my. (laughing)
Most of what we make is
scary, I will say that.
We make monsters for
everyone from home haunter,
all the way up to amusement
parks, and big events
all around the world.
We've been working together for 35 years.
It's been glorious.
- Yeah, wonderful.
(laughing)
- [Marsha] We started
out painting together.
- [Ed] I fell in love very quickly.
- [Marsha] We've been
married almost 25 years.
- [Ed] We've found a way to work together.
- [Marsha] I'm probably more
on the business side, and Ed is
probably more into production.
- [Ed] I can't tell you how
many people have told me
I could never work with my
spouse, and that's too bad,
because you miss half or more
of that whole person's life
if you don't.
- Woo!
(whimsical piano music)
- I think people expect us
to be a little bit weirder
than we are; and we're actually
a little bit boring.
When we get in the car
and go home, it's over.
We love monsters, we just,
we've had enough of it
after a long day.
There's a separation there.
There has to be or you go crazy.
If somebody walked into our
house, they wouldn't have
a clue what we do.
In fact, we keep it all kind of secret.
Yeah, people are surprised
about that with us.
We like it that way.
It's really special to
do something you love
with somebody you love.
- [Marsha] We make monsters,
but whatever our personalities
kind of mesh with each
other, so it works out.
- You know, you really can
establish a good relationship
as you're dripping zombie blood.
- Right.
- That's the kind of
woman I need in my life.